- But Chrissy was talking
earlier about cleaning the house.
Are you a neat freak? Or are
you just kinda like whatever?
- Oh wow. You really want to
put me on the spot, don't you?
- [Kelly] Yup. Yup.
- I feel like...I mean,
I'm not married yet,
so you know, I really want to get a catch.
So I don't know if I need to put out there
that I maybe or may not be neat.
- You should put out who you are.
(chuckling)
- I'm a... it depends on the day.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- But isn't it like interesting
if there was a chance
to like know beforehand
who you're gonna date
and if they're messy,
cause that's a big thing for me.
- [Kelly} Yeah
- Is it for you?
- They can't be messy?
Um, I... um,
I don't know. I've never
really been around...
like my ex he wasn't like a messy person.
So like I've never really
been. Oh, I have had-
(chuckling)
- Let me tell you.
- [Kelly] I have had a
roommate that was very messy.
Like you'd find food with
like ants on a plate.
- Me too.
- And I was like,
not into that at all.
- Well that's something
that it's terrifying
I feel like I want to
keep the mystery out there
because you know, you never know.
Maybe, I still got to
get married at one point.
- Yeah. Or not
- Or not
- Yeah
- But, um,
it would be nice to know beforehand
because that's a big
deal breaker for me. Like
- Yeah
- You're in the relationship
and then you start kind of living together
and you're like, oh wow,
this is not gonna...
Maybe like an app
- [Kelly] I think it seeps over.
- Like an app?
- I think it seeps over
No, I think it seeps over.
If you're that messy and cluttered.
Cause I feel like if my closet is a mess,
if you walk in my house,
and you see my closet
and it's just, oh no,
that means it's like, oh no inside.
- Exactly, that's how it feels.
- It's a really good representation.
My house is a really good representation
of what's happening inside.
- I just, sometimes,
wish that there was like
an app that you could be like
I'm 6'1'' and very messy,
or not messy.
- [Kelly] (chuckling)
- So you can find like
your partner, you know,
like each sock, you need a
right sock for the left sock.
- [Kelly] But you can't
even get people to like
post a real photo of
themselves. It's all filtered.
They're not going to tell
you if they're clean or not.
At this point,
you're showing up probably
going that's...wait.
- I mean. I think I'm messy ish.
Like the other day, I was
like trying to get, you know,
my clothes on and the cleaning
lady who is my favorite.
I love her Carrito. She's
been with me for a long time.
She cleans everything and I have a big...
I made it a point to have a
big laundry bin in my bathroom
- Just toss it
- so I could toss everything.
I don't know how.
I'm, I'm telling you, it's
the size of this couch,
how there's like, on
the sink, on the floor,
but zero in that big bin.
I'm like, how is that?
It's a foot away from me.
- [Kelly] Yeah
- How am I not landing it in there.
- [Kelly} This Is like me
with people in the kitchen,
I'm like, the dishwasher is right there.
Like you couldn't just
put it in the dishwasher.
Like I... see we could never
be roommates, I'll be like
- I was gonna say, you're
never gonna invite me over.
- No, your invited alright,
I don't care about that.
- It just means we probably
can't be roommates.
(chuckles)
- But I have children.
So you probably don't want
to be roommates anyway.